some of your favorite video game voice
actors are not so happy with their
current conditions I'm Tony and this
game spot news update is going on strike
simply put video game voice actors want
better treatment and pay the SAG after
guild represents voice actors and it has
attempted to create a nice deal for its
members in the games industry although
no agreement has been reached the next
meeting is happening from October 17th
through the 19th and if nothing is
resolved several prominent voice actors
are planning to strike on the 21st Roger
Craig Smith the voice of SEO and batman
and jennifer hale the voice of commander
shepard and samus Iran are also in
support of the strike the strike will
target 11 different developers including
Activision EA and take two sag-aftra
only represents a small portion of
actors so how this will actually affect
the industry is unknown at this time but
we'll be following the story at gamespot
so keep an eye out for more developments
and for all the biggest video game news
you're already in the right place
Oh